thank you guys so much for sitting down
with Collider how are you guys doing
today so for all of you guys this was a
very intense action-packed movie was
there any what was your favorite action
scene to shoot hmm I mean there's
favorites and then there's like most
unforgettable in there my favorite is uh
my fight with Harley Quinn over cuz we
at one point will really be in the crap
out of each other you know you know she
she she pulled my hair and I pulled her
hair back and we just went at it and I
told they kept saying well we need you
know the punch I said well if I punch
her I'm gonna punch her and she says
punched me I was like okay it was like
boom you know and she was like yeah we
went out it's oh that's my favorite
my other favorite I'm not in it is this
girl going down the slide
oh and journey for you specifically I
see you on online all the time talking
to Gail about Black Canary so did you do
any specific research for your character
and and digging with especially with
girls comics I'm trying to find your
character oh absolutely Gail's comics
was a massive influence on me the way
she wrote Dinah in of like minds and the
relationship the banter with the other
women and you know the moment when
Barbara Gordon fires her because she's
like you know afraid she's gonna get
injured again because she's all hard
like that to me was something I grabbed
on to so hard because I was like that's
it that's it she's capable of being this
crazy ferocious street fighter but she's
all heart and so when we meet Dinah
lands in the film she's not yet owned
her full potential and her heart's been
broken because she lost her mother and
so that mother-daughter split is
motivating her to just be shut down from
the world because she's trying to guard
her heart and so such a really nugget
for me
and yes so the comics were a huge
influence for me and just kind of
cracking open dinah for the film and
with you with hunters can you talk about
doing the research for that because she
was I think she was one of my favorites
as well all you guys were my favorites
just like she has some very funny
moments so can you just talk about your
character and finding that yeah it was
fun kind of I mean it was it was great
because you know the screenwriter and
Kathy kind of narrowed down the
backstory because there's a bunch of
different iteration of Huntress and
Halina so so our version is Helena
Bertinelli who's the daughter of this
mafia boss and comes from that world and
witnesses her family being murdered in
front of her when she's 8 years old so
that that's like an incredible backstory
to come with from the beginning that's
some intense childhood trauma that you
never get over and it really becomes her
entire identity is you know carrying out
this revenge plot against the people who
did this to her family and just to like
have something so clear to focus on for
an actor have some have something so
clear with what she wants and what's
motivating her and then you know we see
her in the film where she gets to the
point where her fantasies are finally
realized and then it's like what now
right um and she meets all these women
and and kind of getting to look in the
comics and see how her personality
manifests in the banter there and also
you know her anger she's you know how
that bubbles over her rage but I think
what we played with in the movie was how
that could also be kind of funny you
know and kind of odd like she's not
socialized she was raised away from
everybody you know she was raised to be
an assassin she wasn't raised to be like
somebody's friend she doesn't really
know what that is so that was fun we did
a lot of improv with that of bringing
out huntresses sort of endearing quirks
underneath all of that rage and pain
so should we handicap yeah last question
I couldn't see you guys playing any
other role besides us but if you could
swap characters with one of your
co-stars who would it be if you could
pick one person I know so hard cuz as an
actor you can't imagine yourself and you
then you can't imagine anyone I can't
imagine anyone else being Huntress or
Renee come on you got it you got a pig
Renee I'm sorry
yeah I'm giving up Dinah you got so much
missing down collider absolutely loved
the movie I can't wait for people to see
yesteryears
thank you